what can your fans expect coming up this
summer rest of the year what do you have
planned I'm super excited about it
we just finished a documentary film that
I've been working on for the last you
know over a year and like literally two
days ago we finished it and it's coming
out this summer and it tells and
extremely like personal and heartfelt
side of myself that you know sides of
people haven't seen yet and I'm really
excited to share it is it you - Bren it
is coming on YouTube red well is there
anything you're nervous for your fans to
see or they're gonna learn something
that they don't know about you I
remember like a year ago there was a
clip that got released is a feature you
know spot that showed me crying and I'm
are my fans freaking out because they
were like we've only ever seen Lindsey
be so happy and this documentary shows
the hardest year of my life you know it
was a really emotional year for me I
lost several you know my dad died my
best friend passed away and so if you
know it's a side of me that's very real
and and I feel like I think it's I think
it's really good I'm not nervous about
it I feel like it's important for people
to see that yeah at all maybe help some
people - so realizing that everybody
everybody goes through it
nobody's happy all the time it takes
takes work it's life's a cycle
[Music]